nos pidieron replicar la ecuación es
igual a un médium que multiplica a x 6
por x 2 y como siempre pausa este vídeo
y toma un papel cuadriculado o incluso
trata de hacer la gráfica en un pedazo
de papel ordinario y ve qué tal te sale
la gráfica de esta ecuación porque en un
segundo lo vamos a trabajar juntos bien
hay muchas maneras diferentes en las que
podrían intentar graficar esta ecuación
tal vez la manera más básica es probar
un montón de valores de x de james y
tratar de unir la curva que enlaza a
todos esos puntos pero vamos a tratar de
ver si podemos sacar la esencia de esta
gráfica sin hacer tanto trabajo y aquí
el entendimiento clave es que si yo
multiplico x menos 6 por x más 2 incluso
sin tener que hacer las matemáticas
quiero que entiendas que voy a obtener
una cuadrática voy a obtener algo de la
forma x cuadrada más
más algo más y entonces toda esta
ecuación va a representar una parábola
estamos graficando una ecuación
cuadrática ahora una parábola podrían
recordar pueden tercer canal fx varias
veces así que veamos así podemos
encontrar donde intersectan esta
parábola al eje x ahora bien la forma en
la que esta ecuación está factor izada
hace bastante sencillo ver cuando aquí
es igual a cero lo cual nos da las
intersecciones con el eje x y a partir
de eso vamos a ser realmente capaz de
encontrar las coordenadas de nuestro
vértice de la parábola y por lo tanto
vamos a ser capaces de sacar la forma
general de esta curva y un buen esbozo
de esta parábola así que vamos a
plantearlo cuando es igual a cero bien
para saber cuándo y es igual a cero
entonces tenemos que resolver un medio
que multiplica a x menos 6 que
multiplican a x más 2 igual a 0
así que solo vamos a resolver esta
ecuación de aquí lo importante es que en
vídeos anteriores hemos hablado acerca
de esta misma idea si tengo un producto
de varias cosas y esto necesita ser
igual a cero la única manera en que eso
va a suceder es si una o más de estas
cosas es igual a cero pero bueno si nos
fijamos primero en un medio bueno un
medios medium entonces eso no va a ser
igual a cero pero podría ser que x menos
6 sea igual a cero esto hará que la
ecuación que todo lo que buscamos es
igual a cero o si x más 2 es igual a
cero
eso también harán que nuestra ecuación
sea igual a cero y justo ahí son los
valores de x donde nuestra curva entre
secaría al eje x entonces qué valores de
x hace que x menos 6 e igual a 0
bueno podemos sumar 6 de ambos lados
probablemente sean capaces de hacerlo en
su mente pero lo hacemos aquí con
kallman y obtienen que x es igual a 6
o en su dado caso en x + 2 igual a 0
restamos 2 de ambos lados estos se
cancelan y vamos a obtener x igual a
menos 2 entonces estos son los dos
valores de x donde jesse igual a cero
así que pueden sustituirlos en su
ecuación original y obtendrías a 0 si x
es igual a 6 entonces x menos 6 es igual
a 0 y por lo tanto todo va a ser igual a
0 y si x es igual a menos 2 entonces x +
12 de igual a 0 y por lo tanto sería
igual a cero ahora ya que sabemos estos
valores entonces también tenemos los
puntos en donde nuestra parábola va a
inter secar al eje de las x va a inter
secar en x igual a menos 2 justo aquí y
en x igual a 6 estas son nuestras
intersecciones con el eje x así que dado
esto como encontramos el vértice bien la
idea clave aquí es reconocer que el eje
de simetría para la parábola va a estar
justo en medio de las dos intersecciones
entonces cuál es el punto medio entre o
más bien cuál es el promedio entre seis
y menos dos bien lo puedes hacer en tu
mente quedaría como seis más menos dos
lo cual es cuatro y esto es dividido
entre dos es dos ojos solamente soy
tratar de encontrar el punto medio entre
el punto menos 20 y el punto 60 bien el
punto medio es sólo el promedio de las
coordenadas el promedio de 0 y 0 0 lo
que va a caer en el eje de las equis y
luego el punto medio entre -2 y 6 bueno
su promedio es menos 26 entre 2 lo cual
es 4 entre 2 lo cual es 2 entonces el
punto medio entre estos dos es el punto
20 lo puedes ver justo aquí en la
gráfica y esto quiere decir que por aquí
puedo dibujar mi eje de simetría no para
la parábola entonces mi vértice se va a
colocar sobre este eje de simetría y
ahora como encuentro el valor de tiempo
bien podemos encontrarlo muy fácilmente
si sustituyó en ecuación original a x
por 2 cuál es el valor de que cuando x
vale 2 bueno recuerden elbert se tiene
coordenadas x igualados es decir va a
ser de la forma 2 coma algo ahora para
saber cuál es el valor de que entonces
vamos a ver me quedaría un medio por
bueno cuando x vale 2 entonces tengo
aquí dos menos 6 que multiplica a 2 más
2 y veamos esto es menos 4 y éste es 4
positivo entonces me quedan menos 4 por
4 lo cual es menos 16 y si tengo un
medio por menos 16 eso es igual a menos
8 entonces el vértice me va a tener como
coordenadas x igualados de igualdad
menos 8
esta base de nuestro vértice y va a
estar justo por aquí
2 - 8 y ahora ya podemos dibujar de una
forma general a nuestra parábola se va a
ver algo más o menos así recuerda este
es un boceto hecho a mano así que en
definitiva no será exacto pero lo voy a
intentar hacer lo más adecuado que se
pueda y bueno de hecho tengo una
herramienta que me dibuja simétricamente
lo que pasa del otro lado pero mejor lo
termino ya a mano ahí lo tienen
este es un boceto bastante bueno de cómo
se va a ver la gráfica de esta parábola
la cual es una parábola que abre hacia
arriba